jetzt mal ganz besonderes ihr habt
vielleicht schon mitbekommen der
deutsche web video preis steht an und da
könnt ihr was gewinnen und ihr könnt
bestimmen wer in den jeweiligen
kategorien den publikumspreis des
deutschen web video preises gewinnst
dazu einfach auf den link unten im
infotext klicken und dann wollten in den
jeweiligen kategorien euer lieblings
video einfach anklicken und damit dann
entscheiden mit entscheiden wer dort
gewinnt und auch ihr könnt wo wir gerade
beim stichwort gewinnen sind etwas
gewinne und zwar eine video kamera von
panasonic wenn ihr hier mitmacht könnt
ihr nämlich videozone reporter auf dem
deutschen videopreis werden ihr müsst
nur erklären warum ihr gerade ihr es
werden sonst was ihr drauf habt was eure
talente im bereich video sind am besten
per video antwort mit einem link auf
euren kanal damit wir uns angucken
können und die zehn besten die werden es
dann ich sag mal die chancen stehen
nicht schlecht gerade wenn ihr mit video
antwort hier unterwegs seid dann auch
dabei zu sein so was wollte ich noch
sagen ohne zu lügen genau das ganze ist
dann am andreßen märz auf einer
glamourösen gala in düsseldorf da seid
ihr dann die exklusiven video sollen
reporter und ich drücke die daumen für
euch und sach bis 3